[Música]
hacemos el repaso de las noticias de
economía aquí en directo América de la
mañana Juan Pablo un saludo nuevamente
para usted acá estamos otra vez Ángela y
vamos a hablar de este tema interesante
de los acuerdos de la nueva alianza
entre Nissan y Renault qué es lo que se
sabe es qué es lo que sabemos acuerdos
que se aprobaron el domingo por la noche
y que los directores de Nissan aprobaron
este lunes por la mañana vamos
directamente a estos acuerdos porque van
a ser nuevos proyectos conjuntos esto
también con el otro socio que es
Mitsubishi que pues uno de los más
pequeños de esta Alianza Nissan
invertirá en la unidad de Renault y ve
que pues es el negocio insignia de
Renault que se cotizará en el mercado
Pero esto hasta ahora no ha sido claro
no se sabe el monto y no se sabe cómo
entrará a la bolsa tampoco
renaul reducirá su participación en
Nissan del 43% al 15% esto para buscar
una negociación mucho más a nivel y
porque reno se enfocará también en
Industrias Pues de Francia de manera
interna se espera que esta sociedad sea
más libre equilibrada para los próximos
15 años y hay que decirlo que ambas
partes estuvieron de acuerdo con este
porcentaje la nueva versión radical de
la alianza de 24 años se produce después
de meses de intensas conversaciones
complicadas por preocupaciones sobre el
intercambio de propiedad intelectual
mientras reno buscaba alianzas con
empresas fuera de la asociación incluida
la china
ahora le voy a pedir que hagamos el
repaso de las noticias de Asia se
conocieron ya los nominados Para ocupar
el puesto del próximo gobernador del
banco de Japón esto es importante porque
pues Ángela básicamente porque movió los
mercados asiáticos pero por el momento
se trata solo denominados Para ocupar el
pequeño grupo de candidatos y de ese
grupo de candidatos el Primer Ministro
kishida decidirá el puesto final de
Gobernador la Selección del nuevo
gobernador del Banco Central
probablemente determinará qué tan rápido
el país eliminará gradualmente su
estímulo monetario masivo la noticia es
importante entonces Ángela porque se
trata del cargo que define la política
monetaria de la tercera Economía del
mundo y porque sólo con la especulación
de quién será el próximo gobernador los
mercados se alteraron drásticamente con
el anuncio del Gen japonés se depreció
hasta su nivel más bajo en un mes
tocando la franja media de las 132
unidades con respecto al dólar en la
apertura de la bolsa de Tokio este lunes
esto porque uno de Los favoritos es más
a Yoshi amamia quién podrían seguir la
senda de flexibilidad flexibilización
monetaria para el país bando sea ahora
cuénteme por favor Quiénes son esos
posibles candidatos de los que hablamos
hablemos de ellos y empezamos con
masayoshiyamamia precisamente Quién es
el actual vicegobernador y ha pasado la
mayor parte de su cartera en el Banco
Central redactando ideas de política
monetaria se le conoce como Mister B oj
que son la abreviación de las siglas del
banco en inglés por haber sido el
cerebro de muchas de las ideas no
convencionales de relajación monetaria
del país del banco Ahí donde hablamos de
la palabra flexibilización precisamente
y esto manteniendo las interés Ultra
bajas otro de los nominados es Hiroshi
nakazo quien se desempeñó como
vicegobernador del banco hasta 2018 y
quién fue clave para el período de
expansión cuantitativa del banco japonés
esto en 2006
yamaguchi es el tercer nominado
candidato también quien se desempeñó
como uno de los adjuntos del ex
gobernador del banco en 2010 y quien
cumplió un papel clave en la elaboración
de un esquema de compra de activos los
nominados Ángela pasarían a ser
candidatos oficiales si ambas cámaras
del parlamento lo aprueban pues ahí
estamos con esa noticia ahora Indonesia
el crecimiento económico que tuvo en
diciembre fue uno de los mejores en
muchos años A qué se debió este fenómeno
estamos hablando de nueve años fue el
más alto en este tiempo y esto debido al
levantamiento de las restricciones por
la pandemia y el auge mundial de las
materias primas que podemos ver que es
una alternativa tal vez de Pues el
periodo en el que china estuvo
básicamente confinado estos dos factores
llevaron a un aumento en las
exportaciones a nivel récord de 292 mil
millones de dólares la economía más
grande del sudeste asiático asiático se
expandió un 5,31% en 2022 según
mostraron datos de estadísticas de
Indonesia este lunes lo que supone su
mejor tasa de crecimiento anual desde
2013 y más alta que el 5,29% esperado
que si había pronosticado en una
encuesta de la agencia de noticias
routers recordemos que Indonesia es un
importante proveedor mundial de Carbón
térmico aceite de Palma acero y níquel
muy bien y cómo van los indicadores
seguimos con Asia Porque cerraron las
bolsas allá en terreno mixto atentas a
los rumores del próximo gobernador del
Banco Central de Japón y siguiendo los
datos negativos de empleo que se
registraron en Estados Unidos esto el
viernes las bolsas en Europa siguen
operando en terreno negativo mientras se
registra una jornada de protestas en el
sector de salud en Reino Unido y también
mientras se da el debate en el
parlamento sobre la reforma pensional en
Francia y su cifra del día las cifra son
6,650 puestos de trabajo que serán
eliminados por del lo que se supone que
es el 5% de su fuerza laboral global la
compañía aseguró que el recorte se da
debido a la baja demanda de equipos y
como preparación ante la incertidumbre
económica otra de las que se une a estos
recortes masivos simplemente lamentable
gracias a usted Juan Pablo por su
actualización mañana nos vemos con más
Ángela Claro que sí
[Música]